[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler review of
Joker directed by Todd Phillips starting
joaquin phoenix so i had mild
expectations for this movie i knew what
cain Phoenix would absolutely bring it
here but just the press surrounding it
and some of the critics reviews that
seemed a little off putted by it I was
like okay let's just see what happens
here
let's see if it can hit its full
potential and we're all human you're
still gonna have Heath Ledger's amazing
performance in your head and you try not
to compare too much and what I really
like just noticing from the beginning of
this movie is that Joaquin Phoenix
approached this Joker
much differently than Heath Ledger's
Joker he made it his own in such a good
way where even like Heath Ledger's Joker
from Dark Knight was a little more
cartoony and a little more just pure
villain where this was very human
bleeding to full-on psychopath and he
just nailed it there and I think that
what really blew me away too is this is
Todd Phillips directing this and writing
this here who made hangover movies and
known for comedies and oh my god this
was just spectacular making of a drama
here and a character study that you
would think he'd done a bunch of these
before so that really also impressed me
now
what is really just haunting about this
movie is it deals with stuff that a lot
of people never want to talk about and
that still goes on society with mental
illness what does this movie do so well
well it ties in very relevant topics
about mental illness and the lack
thereof of care for it and also for
people that are poor in poverty that are
sick so it actually hits both of those
really well and our Joker here Arthur
Fleck he is a victim of both of those
things but what the movie does so well
is it doesn't totally victimize him to
make him the sympathetic villain it just
kind of explains where he went from one
area to get to the other
area at the end on fluent Psychopaths
and it just makes it a little more
understandable now where you you always
wondered seeing Joker and cartoon
versions and movie versions who is this
guy and how did he become this crazy and
this did such an awesome job of
explaining that it really is an awesome
origin story and I really like the point
of him being on meds and then when he
started really losing it is when he
actually went off of his meds and what
caused him to be off of his meds when
the city stopped providing that service
for him so that brently just connected
those two themes together and really
just justified so well how he'd become
totally loony towards the end and then
adding these twists that I did not
expect here which was the Bruce Wayne
tie into the whole Wayne family and his
mother and that he finds out that he was
actually adopted and was abused and that
the whole thing was kind of twisted that
you know Thomas Wayne was not we didn't
know who to believe that Thomas Wayne
was actually lying that he was a doctor
that he did neglect him as a child he
had and they just did such a brilliant
job of really just messing with the
Joker's head as it was with your head
watching and then really actually
feeling for him at those points and then
it was enough to really convince us that
he would kill his own mother which was
just oh my god that was such a
disturbing scene and so well done so
this movie to me was also very fearless
which you always weight forward in
superhero movies as much of a fan I am
of Marvel movies in the MCU they always
shy away from really hitting on topics
that touch the soul
they keep it very blockbuster where this
really goes deep into the human psyche
and the mind this is more than any
classic superhero blockbuster movie this
is an oscar-worthy movie this is great
writing this is great acting this is a
great film so for me just to be really
impressed and satisfied that it hit all
those things that you wanted this movie
to be people asked for characters that
are villains you got to go full dark
here and they did they didn't shy away
from that I would have been more
disappointed if they made a safe choice
at the end it didn't get brutal I mean
when he's just smashing his
former co-workers heading in the house
and stabs his eye with a knife that was
insane and so well done the gore was
amazing and that goes to when he shoots
Robert DeNiro in the head that was just
Wow
like just the shock factor of that
moment on live TV that's that's who the
Joker is this is this madman here and
you have to make it someone really evil
towards the end because that's what
you're building up so people complaining
that like oh it's it's too dark in these
times and stuff this is a villains movie
so you have to understand that don't see
it if you don't want to see that you
know so I think it did a really good job
there and again just this earth reflect
character being someone who's been
abandoned by society he feels and by you
know his family and not having a normal
childhood and not getting the proper
help for it so I mean what keen Phoenix
just did so good here and when he would
tap into his anger in this laughing
condition that's a real thing
it was just so impressive in me this
such a real comic book movie like all
this stuff could happen in real life
which is just scary and that's what
makes it so haunting and effective I
think that what's really cool too is
that they had an arrow in it clearly to
add to the times to how inspired this
was by Scorsese films and he helped get
this movie kind of started here so you
know King of Comedy it's a bunch here
referencing that just the suit he's
wearing the Joker towards the end
reflects what De Niro was wearing having
DeNiro in the movie who is the leading
king of comedy and having what really
worked was having the same thing where
like you find out he was hallucinating
even hanging out with his neighbor
that's the girl was that was his love
interest so they snuck that in really
well and I thought that just made
complete sense for the character and was
awesome
because you see in that apartment see
and she's like your name's Arthur right
and then you're like wait a minute and
they go on a date and they didn't so
really well so I mean make sure to watch
the king of comedy of if you haven't
seen it because you'll get a lot of more
what they were doing here but what I
always worry about when I hear movies
inspired by another classic is that
they're gonna be too attached to it it's
gonna be too similar and then just feels
like there's ripping ideas but this did
a really good job of just throwing nods
to it and getting some inspiration from
it but making it its own
I was really happy about and they didn't
obsess over the stand-up comedy part
which I appreciate because I would have
been too much like King of Comedy
I had inspirations from taxi driver as
well so you see that it was just a
really good vision and they hit it it
comes full circle at the end you got
this whole character transformation from
a guy who already was mentally ill to
flaunt psychopathy and why he would
become someone like the Joker and they
just succeeded that so well with such
great themes so for me
Joaquin Phoenix Oscar lock here for Best
Actor he must get it do not let him get
robbed please please please thought
Philip should be clearly nominated for
director and for writing and I really
like the score here - it didn't you know
it wasn't invasive it worked for each
scene and it kind of held back which I
appreciate it because you can really
make stuff too campy especially these
type of movies if you just pump it up
too much it just was kind of it makes
sense the music was a team player here
so and yes shout out to the costume
department just little things - with
having the makeup dripping and stuff was
really something else because you still
saw a lot of emotion even when he's in
the clown makeup also little varley
easter egg is my uncle is actually an
extra in this movie and I caught him
first watch where the scene when Joaquin
Phoenix is going down the elevator in
the hospital you'll see the attendee
who's tending in the elevator next to
him - like a crazy person is my uncle
that is my uncle Christian Marley he's
an actor yes so just one throw that in
there - but I loved also at the end that
they did not have the Joker be the one
who kills Bruce Wayne's parents that's
they stayed true to that classic tale
but they made it that or someone else
but it was a it was clearly a result of
the Joker's action which I liked I
thought it was a little more better to
you know make it its own kind of story
but the same time respect a classic
story there where it might just be too
attached if it was directly the Joker
doing that so I I feel like we might get
another Joaquin Phoenix Joker boom film
that full on him but him appearing in
maybe Robert padder's Pattinson uh
Batman but I wouldn't mind if he didn't
either because this was so good that
you're almost scared now for him to do
it again because it was just almost
perfect here so I
again yeah sure I be excited but now I'm
like oh my god this is just gold maybe
we should just let it be so I'm giving
this one a nine point eight it is a
masterpiece it is my favorite superhero
movie ever made
it will pass dark and I'm a list for me
in that category because it's just the
full-on character story here for a
villain and I've never seen anything
like it so powerful powerful stuff let
me know you thought of it down below I'd
love to hear your thoughts and please
don't be afraid to saying anything you
felt about if you didn't like it you
loved it you thought it was okay let me
know it's all just a fair argument here
and everyone be civil with each other
and make sure to subscribe so don't miss
one of my reviews I do a bunch of movies
TV shows I also do celebrity interviews
as well so make sure to check that out I
appreciate every subscriber it really
helps and please follow me at Steve
arleigh one on Twitter Instagram for
more of me and I'll see you next time